I'm curious because you've been on
YouTube so long do you have like a
favorite YouTube era
favorite YouTuber where you think
YouTube was the most interesting or
anything like the type of content that
used to be really hard but you don't
really hear about it anymore kind of uh
uh I don't know what like
defines YouTube era but I do remember
there was like before before YouTube
made uh the ad pocket links
YouTube made it
okay
[ __ ] Joe Rogan
it wasn't me you're like yes it was for
me I swear no it was it was it aligned
at a time it was the wild west of
YouTube
talking about like the filthy Frankie or
I guess it was gonna happen it was going
to happen unfortunately you were the
biggest name at the time
every time my video gets demonetized I'm
like Felix
oh my [ __ ] god this meme that must be
frustrating I'm so sorry I'm so sorry
people still believe it like genuinely
yeah it's been ever well it was like a
common thing at the time no yeah I get
it but yeah it was because of extremist
videos online oh yeah yeah it was like
some of the [ __ ] that was getting like
insane address it was insane yeah yeah
even then it's still not great I regret
answering this question
I remember though when Not only was it
like the YouTube filthy Frank era but
there was the PewDiePie
good times you just like kind of you
know change your voice
[Laughter]
I remember being in because I jumped in
bright the Brighton water and yeah we
were out on a boat and I was wearing a
fully clothed and I was just like well I
hope I can swim back
okay luckily I made it back but it was
just so uh it was an alternate timeline
where you just died yeah
I would happily die there that was Peak
it was it was great everything's like so
polished now yeah like every everyone is
either like trying to copy Mr Beast yeah
that's a whole section of YouTube that
is a whole video I I do you know
Mysteries I think does really
interesting things but it's so
interesting seeing people who make
videos about Mr Beast or trying to get
his attention which is such a weird
genre of YouTube now I made the biggest
cardboard cutout of Mr Beast and to get
his attention and I'm gonna do it right
now
exactly the same and they all sound
indistinguishable it's so bizarre and
it's like they're all going for the same
genre and it's like what happened to
like telling a story or you know just
having a pace to a video you know just
having a flow there's a lot of stories
that they give this thing to me yeah you
can't tell a story that builds up like
nicely it's like you have to throw it oh
yeah yeah it is this this era of just
screaming do it do everything in five
seconds or you'll you fell off plus
ratio you're irrelevant it's like whoa
and the thought and like the style and
everything is always the same you know I
I feel like you can I'll do a lot of
interesting things and get good views
without needing to scream and
shot things really fast how do you guys
feel about the subtitling of every word
per second and shorts
but in for actual videos I hate it
just have like actual subtitles like the
BBC has a has a guideline for
recommended subtitles
no it's like a it's like a yellow tax
black box it's like is it the perfect
spacing timing it also looks [ __ ]
ugly yeah that's no I think it looks
really nice
you know readability but obviously I
think that subtitles should be you know
yeah it's like you should have them turn
on if you want I don't like the idea of
a 20 minute video it is kind of annoying
sometimes one word and every word
changes it's like at least have a line I
used to do that way back in the day yeah
oh that was the thing yeah yeah of
course like my top funniest moment
videos I was like
painfully editing all the subtitles took
[ __ ] forever you did the subtitles
yeah and I was like well it's always
been a wave it's an artificial way of
adding more like Synergy yeah yeah
because you by doing it you just inject
energy well what is it like the the
gaming people like the oh the whole crew
like they always have every word like
subtitle as well right yeah I could
never make my editors do that no I feel
like 12 seconds hate subtitling normally
let alone subtitles every single one
it's horrible because you listen to the
audio and you're like I think I said
that listen again oh no it's wrong
especially with these like you know
people who are kind of you know biting
off the Mr beastly formula they all talk
so [ __ ] fast as well so it's like you
can't even see the words it's cool it's
like two frames of work yeah you're
right it's pretty bizarre I just there's
a whole genre of kind of like mimicking
this one YouTube it didn't really happen
before uh because you know I mean but
it's just so big I mean it's always
happened with like some of the you know
not not this way right not in this way
you get a lot of PewDiePie knockoffs oh
yeah yeah for sure yeah yeah of course I
don't know first I was different now
though at the time but then I realized
yeah no it's fine everyone it's cool
yeah but I feel like confidence each
other at some point yeah but I also feel
like back in that time like all you had
to do was just like play the same game
that you wanted yeah
well the thing is like I would spend so
much time trying to find like indie
horror games yeah right so if you found
one that was like really cool and then
seeing everyone else who's played the
day after you're just like ah come on
yeah let me enjoy it for a dance let me
have my success I found it I don't know
no no to me it took a lot of time to
find stuff so I was just like oh cool
someone just stole what I did but now I
do it all the time oh yeah YouTube
YouTube is about finding someone else's
thing and be like I'm gonna make that
better yeah
I'm gonna do that but just twist it a
little bit literally the entirety of
YouTube yeah at the time I thought that
that was the case but no yeah that's why
when someone you know like Mr Beast
comes on with it that does something
completely new everyone's like okay I
guess that's the more Yeah the more
people do it the better for everyone
anyway so yeah yeah yeah I remember when
I found Slender the first time oh my
gosh this is gonna be huge and I I found
it that's the first one I remember I
even checked if anyone's ever played
this game before and no one had played
it oh my God
yeah that was so big Terry how many
views did your video get on it like
something stupid right I don't know but
that was fun fun times for me at least
but I mean that just like opened the
floodgates for indie games
oh my God yeah I can't stand horror
games anymore I just can't do it I hate
them I'm surprised you lasted that long
playing horror games because like you
you always said from the beginning you
didn't like playing horror games no
you're right yeah yeah and like you went
through some of the [ __ ] wildest
[ __ ] horror games and it's like where
like you know back in like 2013 2014
when you know I was watching you yeah
whereas just like this is the most
terrifying [ __ ] [ __ ] ever how does
this guy do it for a living
that's cool yeah yeah I mean I couldn't
do that because I remember like I think
you were one of the first ones who like
brought out like the Jeff the Killer
game right and like those kinds of ones
right well you know no no no games
yeah okay you might have found a lot of
Japanese influence from there right
because a lot of the Indie horos are
Japanese
[Applause]
[Music]
it was good oh [ __ ] that's those are
great games as well yeah have you played
many games recently that you thought
were really really good or any games of
recent that really started no no I don't
play that [ __ ] about that that's not
worth it I played Magic the Gathering
Arena do you like inscription you played
yeah I know I like it yeah
[Music]
it's probably my favorite game it's like
a rogue like card yeah yeah yeah yeah oh
even I've heard of that one yeah the
reviews are insane I've heard it I've
heard it's really good yeah again it's
one of those games don't look anything
don't look at anything just play it it's
amazing you won't regret it yeah yeah
I'm so glad I went to it not know
nothing it's one of the best games I've
ever played in my life it's so good
inspired
I love that building games
are so fun you'll enjoy the spider then
I'll play inscription you play say the
Spire all right deal deal all right okay
we gotta do it all right
yeah that was really good I enjoyed
Hades a lot too Hades was so good [ __ ]
the soundtrack went so hard in that game
so good I didn't I didn't listen to any
of the story though I was kind of like
yeah whatever I like that they talk way
too much in that game watch out
all right it's like why don't you
honestly I remember watching I don't
know what [ __ ] episode you guys were
talking about skipping cutscenes and
[ __ ] like that or like kind of early
stuff
yes yes yes yes
I don't have time for this [ __ ] I wanna
play a game oh [ __ ] yes oh my God but
it was so funny because I'm like I'm not
the only one yeah
when I stream I stream the game and
people are like stop
being so mad and I'm like bro it sucks
the story sucks
how are you on no one's side today
Hades right that cutscene was so [ __ ]
[ __ ] you need to go and talk to everyone
yeah
and then it's like go and talk to her uh
Achilles go and go and talk to Hercules
and it's like no and I don't want to do
this nine times again it's like I'll
kill my dad and I'll be done with it do
you have you have you played God of War
no
it's such a smooth transition between
gameplay and cutscene yeah yeah I'd be
interested to hear your opinion
in Elder ring you cut the cutscene there
wasn't really many cut scenes I did Skip
some though I was kind of because I I
tell people they yeah I cut the I
skipped the cutscenes you missed the guy
moaning in the start you're the the
opening oh yeah
oh that's so good there was an edit it
was like just the moaning from the Elden
ring intro
but the thing is I say that I skipped
the cutscenes xandering they're like oh
okay yeah that's normal I'm like
but the first time
they come like mid boss playing this
boss I'm like [ __ ] yeah half health and
then I'm like I'm just gonna sit and
watch a movie no
I refuse some animals
okay I am firmly on your side however
mid boss cutscenes little hype but I'm
hyped up at that point bro voice Act is
a crime okay I'm a voice actor it's cool
whatever uh I think that in the Elden
ring right you know the boss where you
fight the uh the snake in the the blood
uh area yeah yeah yeah see what happens
that mid cutscene I know they're cool
like I think
time or some [ __ ] yeah oh my God you
just go on YouTube
[ __ ] amazing so good that was he you
need to finish it I do I will you know
what I'll do I'll do on the tour yeah
with those games so I kind of like being
kind of lost and not knowing what the
[ __ ] going on no it's perfect for not
looking at guides it's great yeah having
chat back seat you sometimes are so
annoying but even with the lore like I
kind of know like not knowing what the
first is happening well it's [ __ ] uh
Georgia R Tolkien I don't know that's
[ __ ] wrong
[Music]
I'm mixing two George R Martin it's just
the name of the Ring they just made [ __ ]
up I'm like I don't know what the [ __ ]
is happening Whoever has the same name
too yeah yeah you know wash people in it
yeah it is yeah
so I'm guessing you don't play many
story based games then I used to I think
I played too many and now I can't well
yeah I enjoy them I don't have the
pictures anymore I don't know goopy game
of goblin break
I think I noticed when you play too many
games you just you just you know a lot
of the time I'm like the cutscene is not
gonna enhance or like my enjoyment so
I'll just skip it I don't give a [ __ ]
I'm just like whatever get on with it I
don't care
let me [ __ ] play the game like for me
it's all gameplay that's where I get the
enjoyment out of and like the gameplay
Loop
yeah that's real gaming movies yeah
I like characters
have you played a visual novel
I I have I have places
oh yeah every YouTuber played the
picture yeah back in the day whoa It's
pigeon oh The Corpse Party oh yeah sorry
he loved that one that's funny I was
deep in that one yeah I like that one
actually yeah that was huge on YouTube
yeah yeah I feel like I feel like
YouTube or like game Villas went through
a phase where some game developers
literally made games for YouTubers oh
yeah yeah oh yeah definitely I think
that's like still kind of a thing yeah I
like how you're fiddling already
you know how I feel like you know like
when a kid's annoying you it's like
here's your Game Boy go in the corner
and play by yourself this is this is
just me right now with this
it's just like let's go I'll just let me
play with this I'm curious do you
console gamer or PC games
come on yeah that's what we're gonna do
without alarms yeah we've always had PC
gaming team these guys are more console
yeah oh that's cringe
that's why we that's why we cut the
cutscene yeah
what do you mean on water cooled kill
yourself bro
anymore yeah
yeah
if I have a choice I 100 choose console
really yeah the only time my game on PC
is a film I'm streaming that's it yeah
you can just plug in the controller to a
lot of games and then it runs even
better than it does on the TV makes no
sense oh because I love gaming on the
certified
I hate gaming on in front of my computer
yeah
because I want to be comfortable
I can play music
I can do that on the couch you want to
just sit back relax on the couch
sometimes you just want to like you know
sink in a bit more yeah you gotta get a
gamer chair and I hate it
it can even do this I still want it
before my couch yeah no you want to be
focused as a gamer you guys are sloppy
Gamers I can tell now you play these
slow ass games sitting on your account
yeah that's great yeah I play games to
relax
oh yeah I'm relaxed with my 120 [ __ ]
beats per minute heart rate
yeah I saw it was relaxing when you when
you got a little too op and went to an
area that you oh yeah that was scared
then you're like yeah
[Music]
that was fun that was so good and then
you get then you go to the bosses again